well a lot of clark county school
district families continue adjusting to
distance education now on the second day
of school
technology not appearing to be a massive
issue today but there are still some
concerns about
recording lessons eight news now
reporter kristen drummond shows us the
issue i don't know what to think
it's but it's not good stephanie henry
addresses a new distance education
hurdle
the plan was that we were going to have
recordings of her son's first grade
classes
a necessity for this solo mother as she
calls herself
not only raising max but working
full-time
i signed up for this assuming that i was
going to be able to help him
even after he came home from the library
and be able to get access to the
recordings but
if you don't have access to the
recordings i don't know how we're going
to do anything
ccsd sending a notification to parents
just a couple of days before school
started regarding classes being recorded
according to our teacher she said until
every kid in the class has signed that
waiver
and until every kid in the class has
said yes that they consent to it
that for right now there are no
recordings the ccsd guidance states
educators are encouraged to record
synchronous sessions
while not publicly disclosing the
personally identifiable
information of students the district
lists a few ways to achieve this goal
teachers can record two google meet
sessions simultaneously while refraining
from using students names
or showing faces other options include
recording a mini lesson
or summarizing the ideas of the class
i'm just hoping that ccsd
just really gets us ironed out asking
for flexibility as henry tries to keep
her son from falling behind
kristen drummond 8 news now
so parents who want to sign the
paperwork known as the authorization for
release of education records
can visit our website at 8newsnow.com
for a link